we're asked to subtract and we have the
problem 68 minus 42 and what I want to
do here is one just show you how I would
do this problem and then talk a little
bit about why it actually works
so if I have 68 minus 42 one way to do
it and this is probably the most typical
way is to write the number you're
subtracting from on top and write the
number that you're subtracting from that
number below that so we're going to have
68 minus 42 and the thing you really
want to think about or that make sure
you do is that you want to align it
according to place so the 2 is below the
8 they're both in the ones place and the
4 is below the 6 they're both in the
tens place and later in this video it
should be clear or I'll hopefully make
it clear why why that's a good thing to
do all right so then we go to the ones
place and we see an 8 and from that
we're going to subtract a 2 so 8 minus 2
is 6 write that over here
let me write that over here 8 minus 2 is
6 8 minus 2 is equal to 6 8 minus 2 is
equal to 6
and then we go to the tens place we have
6 minus 4 and since their tens place
this is really 60 minus 40 but 6 minus 4
is 2 6 minus 4 is equal to 2 and since
these are in the tens place is really
saying 60 minus 40 is equal to 20 and
I'll make that a little bit clearer in a
second so we're actually done here 68
minus 42 is equal to 26 and you can
check that for yourself if you add 26
plus 42 you should get 68 or if you
subtract 26 from 68 you should get 42 so
I encourage you to do that on your own
time after this video verify that 42
plus 26 is equal to 68 is equal to 68
and also verify what 68 minus 26 is
equal to and you should see that it is
equal to 42 so these are two things for
you to check on your own now the last
thing I want to do in this video is just
explain a little bit more depth why this
actually works and at least in my mind I
like to visualize 68 you won't have to
write it out like this but it's one way
to make sure you really understand
what's going on here 68 is the same
thing as 60 Plus 8
or sixty and eight and from that we're
subtracting 40 - but 42 is the same
thing as 40 plus 2 so we're subtracting
40 we're subtracting 40 and we're
subtracting 2 we're subtracting 42 we're
subtracting 40 and 2 and so you could
view this as really two separate
problems you have in the ones place you
have an 8 minus 2 and that's exactly
what we did over here you have a 6 and
then in the tens place you have a 60
minus 40 which is which is 20 so you end
up with 20 plus 6 and you know that
that's the same exact same that's the
same exact thing as 26